I just got here have we talked about the
Hikaru drama yet uh no I don't really
know enough to comment so but you're
you're just in time to talk about what
happened earlier so I I took a walk I
saw these um I mean it was like a nice
kind of photo scene the the Ducks were
sandwiched between what you these are
geese right or are they just larger
Ducks I mean this looks like a duck I
don't know I got a little bit too close
I was trying to get like a better
resolution so they started like swimming
towards me I assumed they wanted food I
didn't have any food and this guy was
particularly I guess provoked he got out
and then this is the last photo I took
before I started running cuz it started
just sprinting after me I was terrified
I was like clearly in a threatening pose
so the other ones were just kind of
chilling but this
one it had a beef